Linda's with us in Kansas hi Linda how
the hours are going out there I must
have to push not push the button let me
try it again
no dad Linda there you are how's it
going out there it's going well thank
you
how can we help today mr. Ramsey I'm so
blessed to be able to talk to you I'm
the owner of a small business I've been
in business for over 20 years I don't
have any debts
I never took out a loan on the business
and you know we've been profitable and I
have three employees now I was advised
by my landlords that I rent the business
from I mean the space from and by my
financial planner to try you know to
apply for this paycheck protection plan
and right before the coronavirus we
really hustled and we got a lot of
business in so it would be okay I mean I
could get through this without taking
out the loan but I was told that it was
free money and so what to us five do I
take out the loan or do I lay off to
other people that work for me I thought
you said you could make it through it I
can make it through it but only if I'm
by myself because I'm the third person
what kind of business is it it's it's a
service industry specialized okay and so
how long before you run out of money if
you don't take the loan um I would say
three months so why can you not make it
three months I can make it three months
without laying in buy off no I don't
think she would have to lay them off if
you don't lie someone off how long can
you make it if I don't I would say a
month and a half okay
all right so why do you have to make the
decision now to lay someone off or take
well because I submitted the loans to
four different banks I mean if you
didn't take the loan yeah
okay and you a month and a half out
assuming the loans are still available
they may not be but you could take it
then right well that's a good idea
hadn't thought it was after a month and
a half I think you could be turned
around what service do you provide well
it's a it's an art service okay all
right cool
well the thing is what we told our folks
here is are you and your husband and
good shape financially where you don't
have to take an income from the business
for a while uh-huh
I'd say we're okay for a few months
yeah like if you didn't take an income
for one month you could keep your people
yes yeah I would look at you not taking
an income before I laid people off and I
would look at laying people off before I
took out a loan the problem with the PPP
loan is it is a loan it has a term with
an interest rate it is not a grant it
has provisions and you can pull the law
up and read it it's available on the
internet it has provisions for
forgiveness of the loan and that's why
your advisors are acting like it's free
money if you meet those provisions
exactly and if they don't change the
game in the middle of it and you're
dealing with the SBA and the federal
government and frankly I don't trust
their competence and I don't trust
Congress to not change the game so I am
never going to borrow money I can tell
you at Ramsey the first thing that will
happen is is our leadership team will go
without pay the second thing will happen
is is that another layer of our leaders
would volunteer likely to go without pay
the third thing that would happen is is
we would go everybody else skips a
paycheck so that nobody lives it loses a
job and way after that would be
furloughs and layoffs and I think you're
a ways away from this and I think these
guys are just going this is free money
and I don't think it's free money
this ain't monopoly this is real life
those are real dollars and there
want them back if you don't meet the
guidelines I disagree feminine Lee with
the advice you've been given avoid the
PPP avoid the federal loans you're gonna
regret it America if you don't I'm just
telling you